And if my sister happens to live in
America
where there are 4.8 million females more
than male or my sister happens to live
in one of the countries of European
Union where there are 10.2 million
females more than male
and if every man finds a woman for
himself
every man finds a woman for himself and
I agree with you one man should marry
only one woman. Yet there'll be 4.8
million females in America who will not
find husbands. There'll be 1.2 million
females in Germany who will not find
husbands. There will be 10.2 million
females in Bangladesh who will not find
husband. There'll be
4.2 million females in Bangladesh who
will not find husband. There'll be 10
million females in Russia who will not
find husband. There'll be 10.2 2 million
females in European Union who will not
find husband. I'm asking the question if
your sister or my sister happens to be
one of these women.
The only option for them is if the
market is saturated. If one man has
found a woman for himself,
there'll be millions of people in
America, Bangladesh, Russia, European
Union,
millions of women who won't find
husband. The only option remaining for
them is that they either marry a man
who has already got a wife
or become public property.
People say Dr. Zakir public property
such a harsh word. I say this is the
most sophisticated word I can use.
There's no third option. You either
marry a man who already has a wife or
become public property.
Any modest woman,
if
there is no choice for her, she would
prefer
marrying a man who already
has
a wife rather than become public
property. In USA,
in USA having mistresses is common.
On an average, a man before he marries a
woman, he has six sexual partners
on average. Yeah. Some have two, three,
some have 10, 20. On an average, an
American man has eight different sexual
partners before he settles down and
marries one. The statistic doesn't say
after he marries, how many more does he
have? That's not mentioned. So, I don't
know about it. But before an American
man marries a woman, he has eight
different sexual partners.
So having mistresses in America is
common. Five, 10, 20, 100, no problem.
But if you have more than one legal
wise, they have a problem. When you are
mistress, a woman is degraded.
A woman is locked down upon. She does
not get a rights. She doesn't get peace.
She doesn't
live peacefully.
On the other hand, in Islam, if a woman
marries a man who already has a wife,
she gets a due rights.
She's respected. She gets honor. She's
not disgraced.
She can walk with the head up.
So in America, having mistress is no
problem. Law allows you. No problem.
having legally married wife more than
one they have a problem.
So if we analyze
the only solution
for a man
for a woman if the market is saturated
she either marries a man who already has
a wife or get a public property. I know
generally no woman would like to share a
husband. I know that. But a Muslim who
has knowledge of Islam, she would not
mind sharing a husband to prevent a
sister from becoming public property.
Everyone doesn't have to do small.
Normally the percentage of is only half
percent.
That is 15 in every thousand
approximately. So in Islam, if a woman
who has the true knowledge of the dean,
she would not mind sharing a husband to
prevent a sister from becoming public
property.
So one of the reasons is that by nature
women
are normally more than men. That's the
reason you find more widowers,
more widows in the world than widowers.
The woman without husband, the husband
has died is much more than a man whose
wife has died. Because the life
expectancy of a woman is much Oh,